a lot of people have their own different
Nicks and you know you had to be a super
lyricist or story to it just be the
energy to bring people don't like to
look themselves in the mirror that's the
hardest thing to do you know it's to
critique yourself when I started doing
music at first I was selfish your music
you mean then I like you want to flashy
things until you know you grow older you
know it's an adult and you be able to
understand yourself a little bit more
he's an American rapper from Compton
California his major label debut was in
October of 2012 to critical success time
named him one of the hundred most
influential people in the world in 2016
he's Kendrick Lamar and here is my take
on his top 10 rules for success Isaac
guys watch and listen if you hear
something like Kendrick says that you
really love make sure to leave it in the
comments below with quotation marks so
we can keep track of what impacted you
it's a whole world out there man that
believes in what you can do and what you
can say and the energy you bring you
know I'm not even just justify myself a
lot of people have their own different
Nick's and you know you'll have to be a
super lyricist or story to it just be
the energy to bring doing I'm saying
they believe in it but the moment they
feel like you don't believe in that no
more and you're just going with the next
trend where this 808 where there's an
up-tempo slow tomorrow - exactly
they don't believe it you know more you
know the coach you don't believe you
know more so stand behind what you do
and you know the world is gonna move by
and that's not how I look at it if you
don't like to look themselves in the
mirror that's the hardest thing to do
you know it's to critique yourself
rather than pointing a finger you know
and then everybody hates change so to
actually do that and say I'm wrong in a
lot of areas I look at myself in the
mirror and I'm saying wrong in a lot of
areas it takes a lot of will
power we didn't saying so it start with
self first the nickname they've been
inquired since I was like a kid she's
been in the neighborhood know something
given to me by just my homeboys growing
up and calm so that name always good you
know I go back to your sitting down coma
kid I just felt like it was it was a
time for me to grow know not only as a
artist but as a person I want to you
know the world to know me for who I am
and I just said back and reflect on why
to pop you knows one of the greatest web
beings one of the greatest YJ is because
the people feel like they had a
connection it wasn't just some facade
that you've seen on stage wrong you know
on TV people actually felt like you know
it was a part you know what she was
going through it you know your worries
and just life in general you know I said
you know what what better way to start
that rather you know giving them our
real name I don't know why a missing
person my songs are personal I do try to
make up you know personal it took me a
long time to figure that out
you know in that state just in that one
box does not know the world is listen
when I started doing music at first I
was selfish going music you mean that I
like um I got a whole community behind
me now I used to wonder they don't
saying so it's more of a responsibility
because they banking on me to have some
positive life yo me out the City of
Compton it's always been a negative
stigma there so I'm at a point now where
I can walk through any neighborhood and
they be like yo [ __ ] you better go you
better do it for us because at the end
of the day we gonna be locked up I mean
they're locked up in the penitentiary
calling me and say yo I need you to look
out for Milo
my little son or my nephew through your
music like dick I'm sayin so that's a
responsibility I have and that's what
keeps me humble man and just life in
general and my family I'm the oldest of
four you know so I gotta make a way for
them and make a positive life for them
my little brother seventeen now and he's
in the City of Compton he might go
through the same steps and mistakes that
I made you know
so that's what really humbles me man and
keep my head level I think it's all my
best advisors reason which came from
trade is to keep the passion for the
music you know always keep that because
so many people lose passion and now
everything you start to build by the
dollar and that's when you know the
value of the music goes down when I was
listening to NWA anything that I did in
the streets it wasn't from NWA
it was from because my cousin's was
doing it you know I
uncle's like a song really didn't the
songs that they had was just a
autobiography of what I seen anyway you
know so for me personally knowing how
kids react to music that's why I tend to
always have the reasoning behind it it's
still gangsta rap it's still hushed and
some parents may not want their kids to
listen to some records not all records
for some records but at the same time
when I do do these records it's a sort
of responsibility of giving like I said
the happenings behind it you know yeah
you can go kill somebody I'm going to
talk about don't killing somebody but
I'm not going to talk about it was
saying that you risking your life for 25
years times for you know in the state
correctional facility you know it's not
just doing it for fun
we're bottles and they're women around
me and say I'm talking about it with
cuffs and chains you know saying so any
any kid that's that's listening to it
you're going to have a precaution so
that's the reality to be I'm just going
to continue to give people what I know
what I want to know what they don't know
what we all know the reason while every
we on earth today you meet him heard all
these different walks of life it's all
the tests it's like it's almost like an
experiment God's experiment why don't we
go understand that we are put on earth
to love that's all this about everybody
want to figure out how complicated life
is and and break it down this is what I
truly think I I really think that it's
going to keep going on we're gonna keep
going on frustration we keep going on
and go keep going on till we finally go
back down to the simplest word love and
one guy sees that then we had acid but
until then it's gonna be warfare you
want the flashy things until you know
you grow older you know it's on the
thought and you be able to understand
yourself a little bit more I learned
that the things they make me happy you
know I learned that you know that really
money really don't make me I'm learning
that now you know that's not really my
arm my peace of mind having money you
know that's all I learned this year your
support I learned that you know jewelry
and all that stuff for me to make Nabi
and when you learn that you'll be able
to grow grow more as a person you know
what makes me happy is really
challenging myself and knowing that I
defeated my let's go you know and took
myself to the next level a better person
it was Pharrell I think that called you
the black Dylan
that was crazy yeah cuz Dylan was
prolific but I'm sure that's where he's
coming from
yeah Deveny oh I said man if I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna say something yeah I'm
not just going
and that's where dinner you know he's a
legend and he said something he voiced
his opinion and the world gravitated
towards and I want to do that with music
this young dedicated artist can't help
but reflect on those who once doubted
him they never said I wasn't talented
enough they say somebody the industry
Shady you'll need to be doing this
I respected their opinions but at the
end of the day I had to follow my heart
is what I want to do it was a passion I
couldn't shake him and I be hurt now if
I just stick with you because it always
be on my
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because the Kingslayer
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you I'm going to
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I also love
to know which of Kendricks top-10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why
what change you're going to make in your
business after watching this video and
if you like some of the quotes that
other people have shared from Kendrick
down below in the quotations give it a
thumbs up to show your approval finally
I want to give a quick shout out to
Jason Jay Rhys Fonseca from Ryze
online.com friend of the channel who
picked up another copy of the book J
rise really appreciate the love for
those you guys want if you want your
chance at a shadow in the future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipt suit and keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching and continue to believe and
I'll see you soon
make sure you dedicate it you know
kelowna half-assing will get you nowhere
and if I do get you somewhere you ain't
gonna be there too long you know you
gotta make sure you really dedicate it
to the music one of my teachers
he asked me say the day you stop being
scared to touch people and talk to
people that's the day your mind open up
to so many things I try to imply what I
learned in seventh grade even this to
this day challenge other rappers have
you been hearing things coming out of
other rappers that are that are going
back at you or is it is it died down um
or do they just take it as a challenge
yeah athlete is you took it as a
challenge but you know the whole point
of thing is not just a challenge for the
moment challenge for you know the whole
extension of this this hip-hop culture
not just off the height but what we're
going to do after what we're gonna do to
challenge ourselves how are we gonna
make better records how we're going to
push forward and innovate the next
generation coming up rather than just
sticking in the moment of verse you know
so that was the whole point of the joint
in I hope everybody really get the idea
behind it